let me ask you what you think about your
girl Chloe's boyfriend where do you see
things going are their wedding bells are
their wedding bells and I love Tristan
Tristan is a really really great guy
he comes from really good stock Tristan
is the lover that Chloe is so I can see
why the happiness exists it's just a
very easygoing relationship they're
incredibly compatible and their friends
your lighten up a little bit you like
this relation I love this relationship
do you see her going down the aisle with
this guy or going down the aisle again I
see her definitely going down the aisle
again I won't say what she will do as
long as she's happy I'm with her
Malika Hawk weighing in on BFF Khloe
Kardashian and Tristan Thompson's
relationship now that she's tackled her
own dating difficulties on season two of
famously single is gonna marry
Ronnie and wish I hadn't done et chatted
with the 34 year old star at a mixer for
the cast in LA on Wednesday night I'm
confused and uncomfortable altogether
because I came in single started
something in the middle now I'm not in
that relationship it's a lot of things
you could describe what it's gonna be
like to watch yourself back go into this
relationship what's a word tragic okay
so I'll have to keep an eye on that and
Kim Kardashian's expanding fam et has
learned the star hired a surrogate to
carry her and Kanye West's third child
I'm so excited for them to have another
baby Kim wants another baby and she
deserves it she's a good mommy and she
loves her children
Loie had at one point been a possible
surrogate are you surprised that
everyone might have been a possible
surrogate at some point oh he's great I
mean the fact that she hasn't had a baby
yet I think all of us know she's gonna
be an incredible mom why not use her
nest why why do you think it was didn't
end up being somebody the family I think
was probably just smarter okay
I was like could you imagine the fights
between Cameron Chloe like what would
she see in those ten months I mean I
have no idea I feel like I just have
only think about is refereeing the stuff
I want no part come on
I do feel like you maybe would have been
like what are you eating what are you
doing like she's very low nice for sure
they're all very organized so it would
have been a very interesting book it's
happening the way it is for a reason
she'll do just fine
[Music]